The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: It's a bit better,
my heart's back in place.
I'm glad that not
everyone's gone.
AUDIENCE: Well you mean passed
out and died from the test?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, no there
were a few students left.
PROFESSOR: That's
good, that's good.
I think once we release the
results everyone will calm
down, and we'll realize that
the mistake was on our part.
AUDIENCE: The mistake?
PROFESSOR: I mean the results
are lower than what we thought.
And it's because we
haven't covered something
that I will cover today.
So we think-- well we
talked about it yesterday,
and we think we haven't
done enough algorithm
design with you guys.
So today I have
problems, and we're
going to come up with solutions.
AUDIENCE: Are you
not going to tell us
what [INAUDIBLE] number is?
PROFESSOR: It's in
the lecture notes.
It's actually quite boring.
I promise it's really boring.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: And if you want
to do that next time when
we'll actually talk
about numerics.
The thing is numerics
are straightforward.
Once you learn the
algorithms you're
not going to come
up with a new one.
I'm pretty sure about that.
Like you're not going to come
up with a revolutionary way
of adding two numbers.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
You never know.
PROFESSOR: Well you
can tell me why.
Think about it and
then you can tell me
why you are not going to.
AUDIENCE: OK, got it.
PROFESSOR: OK so let's
start with a problem.
We know what sorted
arrays look like, right?
1, 3, 5, 6, 7, 9, 12.
This is a sorted array.
If we're given a
sorted array we know
how to find the
number in it, right?
What's the running
time for that.
AUDIENCE: For any given number?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well what's
the best way that we know?
AUDIENCE: Logarithm.
PROFESSOR: Log and
binary search, right?
Well instead of this we're
given a shifted array.
And shifted means
that-- say you're
shifting the array
by K elements.
We're taking these guys.
So the array is
shifted to the left.
So these K elements
end up on the right.
These N minus K elements
end up on the left.
So 7, 9, 12, 1, 3, 5, 6.
So still N elements they are
shifted by some number K.
And I want to find one
number, e, in the array.
I don't know K by the way.
We just know that
it's a shifted array.
This is 12.
So the first thing
you do is figure out
how much time you
have for this, right?
If you're on a test, you
roughly know how much time
you have for a problem.
If you're on an
interview you have
to figure out how much
time the interviewer is
willing to give you for problem.
And spend the first,
I don't, a third
of the time thinking maybe.
Come up with the best
solution that you can.
And then stop there,
and start talking.
So the first thing
you do, you want
to make sure that when
you run out of time
you have something to say.
The most awful thing you can
say is, dude I'm going home now.
Or leave the answer blank.
If you leave the
answer blank we're
not going to give
you points, right?
So not good.
So what's the worst
answer you could give us?
OK worst is a bad term.
What's the brute force
solution to this?
The solution where we don't
care about the running time,
but we want the correct answer.
AUDIENCE: Look everywhere.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So do a linear search.
Pretend we don't know
anything about this array.
Lose the information that
it's a shifted array.
Linear search
running time order N.
OK so this is
something, at least now
when your time runs
out you have something.
You're not going to
leave empty handed.
Let's start thinking now.
Next step.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
can we shift it again?
PROFESSOR: So the
fact that it's shifted
means that-- so originally
it was sorted, right?
But now instead of it
being completely sorted,
you have all the elements
are shifted to the left.
And then so there's a
rotation thing going on here.
So these elements
got out of the array
and then they are put back
in from the other side.
AUDIENCE: Why do we do that?
PROFESSOR: That's how
the info looks like.
We don't do it.
It was done to us.
AUDIENCE: Oh OK.
So now what do we want?
PROFESSOR: We want
to find an element--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
PROFESSOR: --despite the fact
that the array looks like this.
AUDIENCE: Do we know that
the list that we have
is shifted already?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So we're promised that
this is a shifted array.
So it will look like this.
But we don't know what K is.
If we knew what K is,
could we do something fast?
What would we do?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you'd
just re-shift [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so
if you re-shifted
what's the running time?
AUDIENCE: For order
K [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so if
we actually shifted
and then do a binary search
it's order K plus log
N. So for big K's
that's not better.
AUDIENCE: Why is it not
order N plus log [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You can say that
since we don't have any promise
on K it's N. It's order K if
you can shift things out of both
N's.
With Python this
would be order N,
just popping out one element
is order N in Python.
So this is assuming
a smart array.
Otherwise if it's
Python, good point.
It's straight up order N.
So now another good point.
You have this solution, and you
have the brute force solution.
They have the same running time.
You run out of time.
Which one are you
going to code up?
Which one are you going to show?
AUDIENCE: The simpler one.
PROFESSOR: The simpler
one, excellent.
So the reason is,
if you're on a test
it's probably give the
pseudocode, then analyze it.
If you're in an interview
the guy will ask you OK,
what's the running time?
Code it up on the board in
C, Java, whatever he knows.
So you want to code
the simplest solution,
because that reduces the
chance that you'll have bugs.
So that gives you
the most points.
So this solution
shows more insight,
but it doesn't have
a better run time.
Stick to the simple solution.
However if you
have this then you
have some insight
on the problem.
So you can keep
going and hope you
can come up with
a better answer.
So if we knew K, one
thing we could do
is reduce the array
to an unshifted array.
What's another thing we can do?
So I claim that
if you know K you
can come up with a
reasonably easy log N method.
AUDIENCE: If you're
doing binary search,
like if you just pretend like
the array is all together,
but if you know K. So let's
say you're looking for 6.
Then you'd say oh well I'm
going to split the array half,
but you're actually
going to start at K
and then split it in half.
So it's like you pretend that--
PROFESSOR: So what
you want to say
is you have a pretend
array in your mind, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
It's [INAUDIBLE] by K.
PROFESSOR: And you want to
access the middle element
to see if what you're looking
for is bigger or smaller.
Instead of looking at
the middle element here,
you look at the
middle plus K, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Oh, there you go.
Plus K.
PROFESSOR: This is one way of
doing it, good running time.
The problem is it's hard.
You'll have to rewrite binary
search and hope it works.
What I would do,
given that I've had
a bit of time to think
about it, is this is sorted.
This is sorted.
So two binary searched are
also going to be log N time.
Two binary searches,
two lines of pseudocode.
The running time analysis
is pretty simple.
Correctness is
also pretty simple.
And also this gives
me some insight
on the rest of the
problem I claim.
OK so if we have K we can do
log N. What if we don't have K?
What do we do?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Figure out what K is.
PROFESSOR: All right let's try
to find K. We know how to do it
if we have K. So let's try
to find K. What-- if I want
to arrive to a
solution that's log N,
how much time can I
spend on finding K?
OK so let's find
K in log N time.
AUDIENCE: Binary
search for minimum?
PROFESSOR: Binary search--
so I like binary search,
because binary search
is an algorithm that
runs on an array.
And that runs in log N time.
So if I'm able to make it
work I know everything's
going to be right
in terms of time.
So what do you run
a binary search for?
AUDIENCE: The smallest
number possible?
I guess that's kind of going
through all of them, though.
It doesn't really help.
PROFESSOR: So if
you have the min.
Sorry, you can
speak in one second.
AUDIENCE: Oh we have the min!
PROFESSOR: So no, if
you can't have the min.
I think it's good insight.
So if you knew where the min
is, you know this is K, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: So this
is the minimum,
that's K. OK, what
were you going to say?
AUDIENCE: Oh for
just binary search
it would not
[INAUDIBLE] minimum.
I was thinking that if we start
at 1 we will see to our right
and left.
And the point where
[INAUDIBLE] are ending
is where we have something
larger to our right
and something
smaller to our left.
PROFESSOR: OK so there's
a discontinuity here,
that's what you're
saying, right?
So this is sorted.
But then at this
point this breaks.
AUDIENCE: Yes, we are kind
of finding that point where
something to the
right that's greater
than [INAUDIBLE] and
something to the left
is also greater
than [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so let's
see if we can do that.
So for binary search you
have to go somewhere.
So in our case we're
trying to get K, right?
And we know that it's
somewhere between 1 and 10.
And what binary search
does is it makes a guess.
It says hey, I think it's
in the middle of the array.
So it will probably
guess n over 2.
And it makes a
guess and you have
to tell it was the
guess too small,
or was the guess too large?
Because this is what
allows you to recurse
on either the left interval
or on the right interval.
The problem with a discontinuity
is, if I guess here,
and if I guess here, I still
don't see the discontinuity.
So it's good inside,
but it's not enough.
I need a little bit more.
Yes, 2, 3 hands oh wow
you guys don't got it?
AUDIENCE: So I think
we can arbitrarily
take the halfway point
instead of subtracting
from the first element.
And then if it's
a negative number,
then discontinuity
will be in this half.
If it's [INAUDIBLE] it
will be in the other half.
And then you recurse on that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's draw this up.
So in a sorted array the
numbers look like this.
In a shifted array
we splice it here,
and this guy goes to the right.
So it's like this
and then like this.
So this picture shows me the
insight that I had before,
that this part is sorted
and this part is sorted.
The missing part,
which I just heard now,
is that since the whole
array was originally sorted,
this guy is smaller
than this guy.
So if I draw a
horizontal line here,
I can draw a horizontal
line somewhere,
and this and this
will not cross it.
So this whole thing
is taller than this.
So by the way, K was where
the discontinuity was, right?
You said discontinuity.
This is K, it's somewhere here.
So this is a better.
So if I make my guess and
I land somewhere here,
I can know that my
guess is too big,
because it's below the line.
If I make my guess and
it's somewhere here,
I know my guess is too small,
because the number that I
see here is above the line.
Who sets the line?
The first element here.
So this is how you
look at it graphically.
If you don't want to
look at it graphically,
this was a sorted array.
If this is the Kth
element, then everything
here is smaller than it.
So all these guys are smaller
than the first element.
OK so honestly who
understands the solution?
3, 4, OK.
Oh, OK pretty good.
Do we want to code
this up, or do we
want to look at another problem?
OK who wants to look
at another problem?
Clear majority, all right.
Usually I have to
do both choices,
because not enough people are
paying attention to get this.
So I am happy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
All right so before I start
another problem, one thing
I want to say.
Not only do I have a
solution for this problem,
but I have a
process that allowed
me to go from nothing to
a few partial solutions.
And while I was doing
that, I was getting insight
and I was making sure that if
I run out of time before I have
the final solution, I don't walk
out of the room empty handed.
So I don't just want to
show you the final solution,
I want to show you the process.
You can look at the notes
and see the final solution.
That's not everything I
want you to get out of this.
OK, problem 2 has a heap.
And this is a minimum heap,
so it looks like this.
So this is a minimum
heap, N elements.
And I want to extract the kth
smallest element in the heap.
So if K equals 3, this is the
third smallest element, right?
K equals 4, it's this guy.
5, and 6, 1 and 2 are here.
OK the good running
time that we want,
because this is a hard
problem so we give you
the running time,
is K log K. However
before we do that I want to
hear some brute force solutions.
AUDIENCE: All of them.
PROFESSOR: And?
OK you need to sort them first.
So this heap is actually
an array, right?
2, 5, 7, 6, 8, oh
it's 6, 9, 8, sorry.
So you're saying sort
the array, then K--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK what's the
running time for this?
AUDIENCE: Log N.
PROFESSOR: All right
we have a solution.
We're not going to
leave empty handed.
OK let's try to go a bit better.
What's another way
of going it that'll
give me a better running time?
AUDIENCE: You could pop 5 of
the K elements off of the--
PROFESSOR: All right so
this is a mean heap, right?
So it has find min.
And find min runs in order
log N. So if I call it K times
I'm going to get the
K smallest elements.
By the way heap sort
says pop and times,
and you'll have all the
elements in sorted order.
So we're doing a
heap sort, except we
stop when we lose
interest after K elements.
So we're down from
N log N to K log N.
So I would be interested in
hearing a solution that's
worse, because it would
look like N log K.
But shows me more insight.
So by the way this is good.
You're already K log N. So
K log N, the correct answer
is K log K. Small
difference, right?
It's a logarithm factor.
At least it's not an N factor.
If you code this up
chances are we're
not going to be able to
distinguish between this.
So you'll never
see this on a PSet.
So you're almost there.
And this is just applying
straight up knowledge
that we had before.
Let's look at this
solution, if anyone sees it.
Before we attempt K log K.
AUDIENCE: In another
case would we
just pop off first K elements,
why would that be in log N?
Because it's actually
an array, so I
would think that we'd
just take the K time.
PROFESSOR: So this is a heap.
If you don't maintain
the heaping variant
after you do the
first pop you're
not going to be able
to do the second one.
OK, cool.
So let me give you a hint.
How would we find--
if this is an array--
how do I find the minimum?
2, 5, 7, did I forget something?
No.
Let's pretend this array doesn't
start with 2, because it's
boring if it starts with 2.
How do I find the minimum?
I keep one variable that says
the best I've seen so far,
right?
Let's see, N-- oh
this is still boring.
Let's start here.
So we start with
best seen equals 7.
Then when we go to 6 we see,
is 6 better than best seen?
If so, replace best seen with 6.
If not keep going.
Then I get to 9.
Is 9 better than best seen?
Nope, keep going.
Is 8 better than best seen?
So I compare every element
with the best seen,
and then whenever the element
is better I do a replacement.
And then at the end, best seen
will have the smallest element.
So this algorithm
works for k equals
1, which isn't very useful.
So can we generalize
this somehow
to-- so we have a
running time here.
That might give you a hint about
how we want to generalize it,
and I want to generalize
it for all values of K.
AUDIENCE: If you go to the
power of 2 then it's less than--
the nearest power
of 2 less than K--
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: --that element, and
iterate forward with your best
seen.
Does that make sense?
If you want the kth, if you
want the tenth smallest element,
then it has to be
after the 8th row
because it's the next
level in the tree.
Does that make sense?
That doesn't make sense.
PROFESSOR: It makes sense,
but I don't think it's right.
So you're thinking that
the tenth smallest element
has to be somewhere
below, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, and then pretend
that there are numbers here.
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, do
you see what I'm saying?
So this is a heap.
So I can keep filling
it with bigger elements,
and 10 is here.
However you can
do something else
to limit the size of the heap.
It will give us a
different running time,
but you can do something.
You can think about it.
How can you chop up
some of the heap?
For example if I have
a heap that's ten deep
and I look at the fourth
element, what can I do?
You can think about that.
And let's try to get to this.
So I'll accept an
answer for either
how do we limit the
heap in that case,
or how do we generalize
this algorithm.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You want us to
remember the smallest K
elements, you'd make a max
heap [INAUDIBLE] K [INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so
I want to have--
I'll break down your
solution into parts .
So you want to have a bag of
the smallest K elements, right?
So instead of the best seen, you
want to have the K best seen.
And once you have a bag you want
to go through your elements.
And then if you have
something that's
better than what
you have in the bag,
you want to put that in the bag.
Suppose I have,
suppose K equals 3,
and I have 2, 5,
and 7 in the bag.
And I see 6.
Who do I want to
compare it with?
The biggest thing
in the bag, right?
So if I want the K
smallest elements,
if this guy is
smaller than anything,
these aren't the K
smallest elements anymore.
So I want to take the
maximum in the bag,
compare it with what
I'm seeing right now,
and if what I'm seeing is
smaller I want to replace it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Because I
keep doing this maximum,
I keep asking this
maximum question,
this has to be a max heap.
That's why he said max heap.
So you did all
these steps at once
and then gave me
the final answer.
But this is how you
do it step by step.
So it looks like finding
the minimum element,
except you have a bag.
And that bag has to
be a maximum heap.
And the original heap
is a minimum heap.
So the fact that you have
to use a maximum heap
is a bit nontrivial.
Good answer.
All right so we
have K log N, and we
have N log K, so choose what
you want to have in your log.
We have a solution for you.
How about this.
How are we doing here?
So suppose I'm looking
for the fourth element,
and my heap has 10 levels.
How can I chop it--
how can I reduce
the number of things
I'm looking at?
AUDIENCE: You can reduce
it down to 4 levels.
PROFESSOR: I can reduce it
down to 4 levels, exactly.
So this heap has log N levels.
And my K is smaller than log
N. I can reduce the heap down
to K levels and discard
everything below.
And the reason for that is
we have a mean heap, right?
So if we go down from, on any
path from the roots to a leaf,
the values have to
increase, right?
Otherwise it's not a mean keep.
Otherwise there's an invariant
violation somewhere there.
So as I go down on any path
my numbers are going up.
So these are all the
paths of length 4.
All of them have
to go through here.
All the paths of length
4 will stop here.
So I know that
everything here has
to be bigger than
the first 4 elements.
So if I reduce this to K and
I discard everything else,
what's the running time?
So if I use my find my
extract min algorithm before,
what was the running time?
AUDIENCE: It was [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So it's not the--
AUDIENCE: Oh sorry it's the--
PROFESSOR: So what's
one operation in a heap?
If I have the height of a
heap, what's an operation?
How much time does it
take to do one operation
as a function of the
height of the heap?
So if my heap has h
levels, in this case
h happens to be log
N, it's order h.
So if I reduce it-- I'm not
reducing it from N to K.
I wish I could.
I'm reducing it from log N to K.
So for really tiny K's,
this becomes order K.
And my total running
time is K squared.
So I'm going to do K
operations, K extract mins.
OK now the reason I wanted
to entertain this is I
claim it's going to be useful
to help us find the answer.
So everything that we have
here gives us some insight
into what the correct answer is.
Well what our correct answer is.
There might be others.
So let's think for a bit,
and see if we can do better.
Am I covering something?
I hope not.
So by the way, when you
have problems on your own,
say you are looking at
CLRS or at old exams,
you want to give yourselves
half an hour, an hour to think.
And just this process
alone is going
to help you do better on a test.
Because while you're thinking
you're going through everything
you know.
And you're rearranging
stuff in your brain
in a way that will be
easier to access it later.
So now you're going to think,
what do I know about heaps?
What do I know that
takes log N time?
takes N log N time?
And your brain will
be better at answering
these kinds of questions later.
Now we're not going to
give you 30 minutes,
because that would make
us run out of time.
AUDIENCE: You want to reduce
it down to K elements.
PROFESSOR: I want
to only have to look
at K elements, that's good.
AUDIENCE: Otherwise you
can't plug K into the search.
PROFESSOR: Yep,
OK so that's good.
AUDIENCE: Which is interesting,
because it's K log K,
and that kind of
suggests that you'd
have K elements in the tree.
But then you're searching
for each one in the tree.
PROFESSOR: So
maybe I'm not going
to be able to cut this heap
into K elements, right?
I'll have to do a bit more.
AUDIENCE: Can you cut
this heap into K elements
and use that heap to
do our [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Let's see
how we'd cut this heap.
First off let's
see how this keep
would look like if it's cut.
How do we find the
first K elements here?
How do we find
the first element?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's the root.
Second element.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What do I look at?
If I want to select the
second element in a heap,
how many elements do
I have to look at?
Two, 5 and 7, because everything
below will be bigger, right?
OK I look at them,
I compare them,
I know 5 is the smallest one.
Now suppose I want to
find the third element.
Who do I look at?
7 or the thing under 5.
So 7 is still in
the race for sure.
And then I have to look
at the children of 5.
Right now we're looking at 3.
Suppose this has some
really large kids.
As in numbers.
And I find that this
is the third element.
Who do I look at for
the fourth element?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so this
isn't in the race
anymore, because it's the third.
The fourth has to be
either of these two guys.
Or the kids here, right?
And it happens to be 7.
So I take it out.
If I want to look at the-- if I
want to find the next element,
who's in the race?
This guy gets out of the race.
AUDIENCE: 7's kids.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK so
we have something.
We're not really
cutting up the heap,
but we are sort of computing
where the blade would
go if we wanted to cut it up
in K elements and N minus K
elements.
Does this make some sense?
Nods, no nods.
AUDIENCE: I mean I
guess you're never
going to be going
down farther than K.
PROFESSOR: So let's just
understand the concept.
And then we're going
to do one more pass,
write pseudocode, and
understand the running time.
Because this is still
confusing, right?
We'll need one more
pass, otherwise
we can't write the
pseudocode into it.
So does the concept make sense?
AUDIENCE: Is that K log K?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the idea here is that I
have a horizon that says,
what are the next elements
that I'm willing to consider?
And first the horizon
starts with just the root,
because I know that's
the minimum element.
And when I take an
element out of the horizon
I put in its children.
That's what I did all the time.
So given a horizon how do I
know what the next elements
to extract out of the horizon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The mean, OK.
So I want a data
structure for the horizon
that can extract means quickly.
OK what am I going to
use for the horizon?
A min heap, excellent.
So let's try to
go for pseudocode.
Suppose we have H as
our original heap.
So H is a mean heap.
We will make Z be our horizon.
I can't use H again.
It would be nice if
I could, but I'll
use Z because Z's also
a letter in horizon.
So Z's the mean heap.
And then first I
will insert into Z.
I'll insert the
heap's root, right?
So Z dot insert H of 1.
Remember that heaps
are actually arrays.
I hinted to his earlier.
So these nodes have are
elements in an array.
So this is the first element,
second, third, fourth, fifth,
sixth.
So we're using array
backed heaps, and H of one
is going to be the root.
Then I'm going to compute the
first K elements like this,
for K in range-- sorry,
for i in range K,
so K is going to go from 1 to K.
What I want to do?
Take, compute the ith element.
How do I do that?
AUDIENCE: Extract min.
PROFESSOR: i equals
Z dot extract min.
And then I want to insert
the children in the horizon.
Right?
How do I do that?
AUDIENCE: 2i and 2i plus 1.
PROFESSOR: OK so this is
if I know the index, right?
When I'm putting
things in the heap
the keys are going
to be the values,
so that I can take
out the minimum.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] heap
first and then inserted H Y.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
This is empty.
And this is the input.
OK so I need to use the
numbers as the keys.
So when I extract
something out of the heap,
so when I extract the first
element it's going to say 2,
it's not going to say 1.
If I want to--
AUDIENCE: Why wouldn't Z dot
extract [INAUDIBLE] because--
PROFESSOR: So this will give
me the next key in the horizon.
AUDIENCE: But-- oh I
see, you're starting out
with just the first one.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh and then you
want to add in the next.
PROFESSOR: So at the
end of this whole thing,
if I'm extracting them right, I
can return this variable here.
Because after K durations this
is going to be the Kth element.
So I return it and I'm done.
The problem is I want this
guy's index too, right?
So I can't just store
the key in the heap.
I have to augment the heap
to let me store values.
And I have to store the index.
So for this guy would
have Z insert H of 1,
and then it's index 1.
Then when I get
out the ith element
I'll also get out it's index.
A variable name for that?
AUDIENCE: j.
PROFESSOR: j.
OK why would you name
your variables like this?
In the previous section I had
a similar suggestion, i, i.
So why would you name
your variables like this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Job security.
All right.
So it's OK here.
Try to not to do that when
doing an exam or an interview,
because it reflects
poorly on you.
For an interview and for
an exam you'll get us upset
and we might be less lenient.
Or at least explain
what you're doing.
So extract min is going
to give us the key.
And it's going to give
us index in the heap.
What do we do afterwards?
AUDIENCE: We add to
[INAUDIBLE] H of--
PROFESSOR: All right
so when we take out 2--
so we start out with
an horizon of 2.
When we take it out 2's the
only thing that's in the horizon
first.
Then we take it out and its two
children get in the horizon.
Then we take out
one of the children
and put its children
in the horizon.
So when we take
out a node we want
to put its children
in the horizon.
So we're going to say Z dot--
AUDIENCE: Insert.
PROFESSOR: Insert.
What do I insert?
AUDIENCE: H of I times 2.
j times 2.
PROFESSOR: See?
It's working already.
The job security
thing is working.
And?
AUDIENCE: 2j plus 1.
You have to do two lines.
PROFESSOR: OK, sweet.
OK.
Does this work?
I mean does this do what
we wanted it to do earlier?
AUDIENCE: Wait,
we're extracting oh--
PROFESSOR: All right first nod.
AUDIENCE: I mean if
K is small enough.
Eventually you'll ask for
something that is out of range.
PROFESSOR: Oh so you're
thinking that eventually these
will run out of range.
AUDIENCE: If you have
your really lopsided array
eventually you'll ask for
something that's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK what would
we want to do in that case?
AUDIENCE: Just want to check to
make sure that the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but
otherwise move on, right?
If an element doesn't have kids,
we don't add on to the horizon.
So we need some bounce
checks, exception checking,
things like that in here.
And I won't add
that because that
will make it look long and ugly.
So this is the idea.
OK what's the running
time for this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Cool.
So creating heaps, initializing,
all order 1, insertion,
this heap is almost empty now.
So this is order 1.
Then these happen K times.
And these are all
operations on the heap Z.
And the heap for the heap Z,
it has some number of elements.
And it's not always going
to have one element,
because every time
I'm extracting
one element I'm adding two.
So well how many elements
is it going to have at most?
AUDIENCE: K.
PROFESSOR: OK why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because each time
you add it it's one element.
PROFESSOR: So I
extract one for sure.
And then I add at
most two elements.
So the heap size grows by at
most 1 in every iteration.
So the heap size Z will
have at most K elements.
So now I know the running
for all these operations.
What is it?
Log K. Cool.
So it's K times log K. And
the reason that it works,
it's a bit harder to see.
You have to convince yourself
maybe using this bigger tree,
that whenever you're spending
expanding the horizon
you're expanding
it the right way.
So the idea is
again that whatever
path you take down you're
going to see ascending numbers.
So when you're
increasing the horizon
you're always pushing
it down in such a way
that your invariant is that
all the numbers in the horizon
are smaller then their children.
And so on and so forth.
So the horizon is
always guaranteed
to have the smallest number
that you haven't extracted yet.
And that's really the
only thing you need.
OK does this make some sense?
AUDIENCE: It never would have
occurred to me on an exam.
PROFESSOR: Yeah exactly.
This would not occur on an
exam unless you think a lot,
you're super inspired, all that.
If it doesn't occur
to you what do you do?
AUDIENCE: Go with
the N log K solution.
PROFESSOR: OK, very good.
Wait.
AUDIENCE: K log N.
PROFESSOR: OK, K log N
or N log K, which one?
AUDIENCE: K log N.
PROFESSOR: Why?
Two reasons.
K log N is-- so two
reasons, faster and simpler.
So you write this down.
And you get half score or 3/4
of the score and you're done.
It's better than
nothing, anything,
and getting a 0, right?
I mean 3/4 of a score for
two lines of pseudocode
is reasonable, right?
Two or three lines.
This is three lines probably.
Also on most exams
we're humans, right?
We might mess them up, we
might make them too long.
If we make them
too long, you want
to get the most
number of points.
You'll have time to
figure out one or two
problems at that level.
But if we give you too
many, for the rest of them
you want to have
something simple that
gives you some of the points.
Same for an interview.
For most interviews
most people don't really
have a clue how many
problems you can solve,
how many problems
are reasonable.
So you want, for
every problem you
want to show some
solution reasonably fast.
And then see if they're happy.
And if they're happy move
on to the next problem.
And if they're not happy
only then spend more time.
So this is as important as that.
If you look at the recitation
notes we'll have some problems
and we'll have some solutions.
What are going to do,
memorize the solutions?
Yay, you know how to
solve more problems.
There are probably a
million problems in total.
That doesn't get you very far.
So what you want is to
understand this process
that we went through.
So every time we tried
something we got from some point
to some point with a
better running time.
Well except for here.
And where we had more
insight on the problem.
So this is the important part.
And I'm going to show you one
more problem, really quickly.
We're probably not going
to be able to solve it,
because it's hard.
But we are going
to talk about it
and see if we can
get some insight.
Let's see, what do
I want to erase?
This.
I like that.
All right, so we have an array
random numbers, 7, 2, 5--
this time there's no
order in it-- 8, 9, 4.
And we tell you that the
array has 2 to the N numbers,
to make the problem easier.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
6.
So you have this array.
And we want to answer
queries of this shape.
Say this array is E,
and it has N elements,
and you know that N
is some 2 to the K.
Minimum of all the
elements from i to j.
So you have two
phases, just like we
had on a problem on the exam.
You have a pre-processing
stage where you get the array,
you do some computation,
you save some information.
And then you have
a querying phase,
where you have to answer
these as fast as possible.
I see most people
have unhappy faces.
Bad memories, huh?
OK let's not worry
about that problem.
Let's look at this one.
So assuming you have
as much time as you
want to do the
pre-processing, what's
the fastest way you
could answer these?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you
had as much time
for pre-processing
[INAUDIBLE] memorize it.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So if we compute the answers to
all possible solutions, right?
How would I store that?
So I want to do this in order 1.
So how would I
store these answers?
AUDIENCE: Just sort your array.
PROFESSOR: OK so
I sort my array.
AUDIENCE: Then you want
the minimum from i to j,
so look at the ith element
and that's your [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so figure it out?
Well I mean if I can sort
it I can also say hey,
why don't we use
this array instead?
And then I'll
answer the queries.
You can go off a tangent
trying to sort the elements
and keep their keys.
The important thing is if
you think about it for awhile
and you see that things
stop making sense, back out.
Look somewhere else.
We spent some time trying
to find a solution based
on sorting in my last section.
It's not going to work.
So--
AUDIENCE: Can't you just take
the [INAUDIBLE] from i to j?
PROFESSOR: OK let's
get to that in a bit.
So let's keep that in mind.
Because that's another point
on the trade off curve.
So if I want to serve
my queries in order 1,
then the way I do that is I will
have a hash of all the arrays
that look like i, j.
So all the possible intervals.
And I'll store the answer here.
The minimum the
elements from i to j.
And I can do a hash lookup
in order 1 and get the answer
and return the answer.
How many elements
so I have here?
So how much storage do
I have to use for this?
AUDIENCE: O of N squared.
PROFESSOR: OK N values for this,
N values for this, so roughly
N squared.
What's the time
for computing this?
Brute force, let's not think.
What's the time
for computing this?
AUDIENCE: N cubed.
PROFESSOR: N cubed.
You're thinking.
So I have unsquared
elements here.
For every element
I have to compute
the minimum of potentially
order N elements, right?
So this is N cubed.
I could reduce it to N squared
by noticing that if I have
the minimum of these
elements, and I
want to compute the
minimum of these elements,
really all I have to
do is compute, compare
this minimum with this element.
So every time I start
with an interval of size 1
and then I expand it by 1.
So I have my two for loops here.
And I keep growing my minimum.
So I could get down to
order of N squared times.
So I have one solution
that has order
of N squared time and
space, and then answers
the queries in order 1.
You had a solution you
said where, what you do
is, when you get a query
you compute this, right?
You were suggesting
sorting the array.
That would be N log N. I
would suggest not sorting it.
Do the splicing, you look
through all the elements,
and you find the minimum.
AUDIENCE: I was saying that
if the original E spans i to j
and started at the--
PROFESSOR: So when you
get a query the i's
and j's change for every query.
Otherwise we could
compute the answer.
So we have one answer
where we take order
N time to answer a query.
And what do we do
for pre-processing?
Nothing.
Order 1.
So these are two ends
of a trade off, right?
One possible extreme is that you
pre-compute all your answers.
The other possible extreme
is that you don't do anything
and you brute
force every answer.
And now we want to
find a point somewhere
on this line between
the extremes.
So the answer that we're
going to show in the solutions
uses order N log N space.
And it answers
the query by using
order 1 elements in this
order N log N data structure.
So I have order N
log N partial minima.
And I will only use two of them.
So the total running time
isn't actually order 1.
But we only use
order 1 elements.
Let's start thinking
very quickly.
Let's think for about a
minute, and then we'll
go through the solution.
And there are
multiple solutions.
All of them are interesting
in different ways.
And there are other
solutions that
are equally fun and applicable
with not the same running time.
Let me make some space here.
So like I said, thinking is
a useful process on its own.
So you're getting better
just by doing this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] using
more than one space total?
PROFESSOR: We're
using N log N space.
AUDIENCE: Oh and it
takes constant time--
PROFESSOR: It will only
look at two elements.
It's actually not constant time.
We're not going to worry
too much about time.
It turns out being log.
AUDIENCE: Ok, what
was the order 1 then?
PROFESSOR: You only
access order 1 elements.
Order 1 partial minimum.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Does it have to do
with two different K?
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
what to do with that.
There's probably some
sort of tree involved.
PROFESSOR: So you're going to
want to split things, right?
Into halves.
And you're going to want to be
able to do this all the time.
And we say 2 to the K so we
don't have to worry about,
oh my God what happens if
the halves aren't equal?
You can usually solve this
when you implement the problem.
But it's useful
to not worry about
that when you come up
with your first algorithm.
If you're going to start
dividing in halves.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Um.
PROFESSOR: So that leads
to another useful solution.
That leads to a solution
that takes-- that has N log N
storage and it will
run in N log N time
with N log N element axes.
So what you thinking
of is you're
going to have your array
of elements, right?
And say you want to find the
minimum from here to here.
You're going to have
your array split in half.
So you're going to find
the minimum of this,
and the minimum of this.
But to do that you'll
have to recurse.
So this is also
say split in half.
So you'll have to
find-- so it turns out
that if you do this,
in the end you'll
have log N minima that
you have to look at.
But this is more, this is a
cooler and more useful thing,
so I'll try to put it
on a PSet or something
to make you think about it.
So this is-- don't
tell people yet.
You might have a
solution to a problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what we thought of, or the
way we thought of doing it,
is 6, 7, 2, 5, 3, 8, 9, 4.
So we compute these
partial minima.
We split the array into two.
And these are the
minima that we compute.
Sorry, this is like
this, this is like this.
So everything, so all the
left half then these guys,
then these guys, then this guy.
Everything here, then these
guys, then these guys,
then this guy.
So if your i and j are on
different sides of the middle,
then you do two
lookups, you're done.
If they're in the
same half, then you
have a problem
that's half the size.
So you're going to have
to take this array that's
half the size, 2, 5.
Split it into halves
and do the same thing.
And then we're going to have to
do the same to this other one.
3, 8, 9, 4, split it into
halves and do the same thing.
So in the end you'll
end up in someplace
where your interval ages are on
different sides of the middle.
And you look at two
elements and you're done.
Let's see how much
space this takes.
Can someone tell me a
recursion for how much
space, for how many minimums
I would need to keep?
So space for an elements is?
AUDIENCE: The first
level you have 8.
So go down by an order of 2.
PROFESSOR: So what's
the first level?
AUDIENCE: Of 8 N.
PROFESSOR: So order N plus?
AUDIENCE: N over 2?
t of N over 2?
PROFESSOR: OK S
because it's space.
N over 2.
OK.
And?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You're
missing something.
Look at this picture.
So this is the whole thing.
Then I have a half.
And then what else do I have?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: The other half.
AUDIENCE: Oh, 2.
PROFESSOR: OK so the
difference between these two
is that one of them
gives you order N,
the other one gives you N log
N. So I gave you the answer,
so I can't ask you
for the answer now.
But where did we
see this before?
Pretend these are t's.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
So these are t's, this is the
recursion for [? more sort ?].
So once you put it up you
don't draw the recursion tree
and solve it.
You say this is what we saw
in [? more sort. ?] Therefore,
the solution is N
log N. So this is
how you show you
have N log N space,
and it's pretty clear
that you're only
going to access two elements.
AUDIENCE: I don't
understand how [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: How it works?
So you have your i
and you have your j.
Let's make that one i here.
If you want to find
the minimum, if i and j
are on different sides of the
half, you have this and this.
And these two partial minima
cover your entire interval.
Now if they're on the
same side of the half then
you recurse to a
smaller problem.
AUDIENCE: Well you don't have
to there because you already
have the minimum
of that section.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It wouldn't work
if you had 6 and 2, right?
Or that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well why not
just take 7 and 2 then?
Why do you have to break
up the entire panel?
PROFESSOR: Assume there's
more things there.
AUDIENCE: Oh I see.
PROFESSOR: So if you have this,
now it's no longer true, right?
So wherever they are
here, you do that.
And remember your pseudocode
has to be as simple as possible
to reduce the
probability of bugs.
So you want to do the
simplest possible thing,
not have special cases.
OK.
By the way there's
a study that shows
that for good or bad
programmers, if you have
1,000 lines of code, there's a
constant probability of a bug.
And the constants are
different for good
versus bad programmers,
but it's still a constant.
So how many mistakes
you make is directly
proportional to
how much you write.
This is why we like
simple solutions.
OK, any questions on this?
So we have four problems.
We didn't cover one.
Look at the other one,
look at the solution.
Ideally look at the problem,
think for at least half
an hour, then look
at the solution.
What I want you to take
away is not just oh, here
are three problems, let's
memorize how we solve them.
But the whole process
thing, and how
we played with data structures
and how we used all the hints
that we possibly could to build
more insights into the problem.
OK, cool.